[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is a greatly enlarged view of the
common house fly
this is the cockroach and this is the
bed bug
you may not recognize them as they are
shown here
but you may have met them in the
barracks
in the kitchen or mess hall and at meal
time
the cockroach the bed bug and the
housefly are called household insects
because they infest places of human
habitation
ruining sleep and deficiency destroying
food
and carrying filth and disease it is the
duty of the medical department to
investigate
insect infestations and to inspect
insect control measures that are carried
out by personnel of the corps of
engineers
control of household insects in military
establishments
is based upon thorough sanitation and
upon scientific use of an insecticide
known as
ddt ddt
is particularly useful because of its
physical properties of stability
and solubility
it is easily mixed with kerosene or fuel
oil
and forms a clear stable solution
in this form it has the advantage of
leaving no noticeable residue
although in its pure form ddt cannot be
mixed with water
when combined with a wetting agent it
enters easily into a suspension with
water
ddt acts as a nerve poison and is highly
effective against all household insects
a container treated with ddt is death
slow but sure to flies
with mosquitoes in the same container
the effect is identical
ddt will continue to knock out insects
for months after application roaches in
the same container meet a similar fate
many different types of equipment are
used in insect control
however these are the ones most often
employed against household insects
ddt is issued in both liquid and powder
form
for use in sprayers and dusters each
post should stock at least 45 days
supply of both types of ddt
the three gallon sprayer is used with
the standard five percent solution
of ddt in kerosene it can be used with
the wettable ddt
in water depending upon the type of
treatment required
to allow enough room for sufficient air
pressure
don't fill the tank too full
you'll get the best results when an
operating pressure of twenty five to
thirty pounds is maintained
the five percent ddt solution is also
used in applicators for treatment of
screened windows and doors
the duster is used with 10 ddt
powder
here is the complete arsenal of insect
control equipment
respirator and gloves for your own
protection
bulb and plunger type dusters screen
applicators
and the three gallon sprayer with these
few pieces of equipment
you can control all household insects
concentrate on control of bed bugs
during the winter months
leaving the rest of the year for warm
weather insects
the bed bug is a sociable insect a lover
of blood and warmth
found wherever humans sleep even the
best kept barracks is not immune
the bed bug is a nocturnal insect and
feeds on human blood
the spots on this sheet show it has been
active here
it breeds and hides by day in cracks and
crevices adjoining the beds
its harbors can be identified by the
traces of excrement
the bed bug may also live in the seams
and the edges of mattresses
bed springs and bedsteds offer nesting
space for these insects
a single bed bug lays as many as 500
eggs in a lifetime
and in three months may have up to
twenty thousand descendants
the occupants of the barracks prepare it
in advance for insect control
opening the windows pulling the bunks
out away from the wall
stripping the mattresses and pillows and
putting in the aisle
all shoes clothes bedding rubber goods
and other material
which might be harmed by the spray
and now you're ready to go
treat the wall surfaces using the nozzle
which produces a fan shaped spray
hold the nozzle close enough to the
surface to produce a wet coating
without mist or fog
if the nozzle is held too far away most
of the spray
does not reach the surface
if the nozzle is held too close the
spray forms drops and runs off
a medium wet spray leaves an even
covering
and a uniform crystalline deposit this
is the way it should look
this residue properly placed is the key
to control of household insects
one quart of liquid ddt when properly
applied
will cover 250 square feet of wall
surface
spray the walls to a height of at least
three feet above the level of the
mattress
covering all cracks around joints and
timbers which might offer harbor to the
bugs
now take care of the beds spray the coil
springs and the mattress edge
don't bother with the flat surfaces of
the mattress
spray methodically and thoroughly
this barracks should remain a pleasant
place to sleep for a year or more
a well-kept mess is less likely to
become infested with roaches
than one in which sanitation is
neglected however
even the best-kept mess must be treated
regularly against infestation
before treatment mess personnel make all
the necessary preparations
removing stores from shelves and
cabinets to uncover cracks and sheltered
places
where roaches live and breed removing or
covering all goods which might be harmed
by the spray
upending tables and other movable
furniture and that means
everything the kitchen fires must out
several hours in advance the kerosene
spray is dangerous around
open flame or hot surfaces mess
personnel
clean out beneath fixed furniture such
as stoves
ice boxes and work surfaces and put all
dishes
pots pans and other containers where
they will be protected from
contamination
sanitation is their part in helping the
program of insect control
and now the mess hall is ready for
treatment
no smoking is permitted during spray
treatments
this rule must be observed as long as
the kerosene fumes are present
turn off all electricity as an added
precaution against
short circuits and possible fire
here the method of spraying is the same
as for bed bugs
only the breeding and hiding places are
different
roaches form little clusters or colonies
in cracks crevices and in warm dark
protected places
generally around the lower half of the
room
large roach colonies are found around
moisture and warmth
of all types of food starchy ones are
the most attractive to roaches
treat all the places where flower and
crumbs collect
this is a good example a bread storage
cabinet
or beneath the kitchen work tables
or under the tables in the mess hall
okay now that much of the job's finished
as far as you're concerned that is
here's where the mess personnel take
over again
mess personnel should be particularly
careful to inspect
all equipment produce and other material
before it is put in place it may bring
roaches with it
roaches often hitch a ride on just this
sort of thing
roaches are the most difficult of the
household insects
to exterminate completely constant
vigilance is necessary
with an occasional spot treatment when
roaches are found
spot treatment and general sanitation
are the responsibility of the mess
personnel
events are discovered during the period
between regular insect control measures
a spark treatment of the ant run and the
point of entry
will take care of them
after a few days it's a good practice to
give the mess area
a follow-up treatment with 10 ddt powder
dusting is a check on the previous spray
treatment
moreover it gives you a chance to get
the places you couldn't treat with
kerosene spray
for fear of fire
use the plunger type duster to reach
otherwise inaccessible points
and for general all over treatment
a thin layer is sufficient
the fly presents a different and more
complicated problem
it breathes on filth feeds on filth
carries filth with it wherever it goes
it abounds wherever rotten or decaying
materials are found
from these breathing points the adult
fly spreads filth and disease
for a thousand yards or more
the eating habits of the adult fly are
no more pleasant than its breeding
habits
from here the fly may travel to human
food
carrying with it the germs of dysentery
cholera
diarrhea and typhoid fever
there are four rules for fly control
first destroy its breeding places
control it at its source
flies often breed in great numbers in
stables on or near the post
but not only in the stable itself
outside the stable in and around the
manure pile
and in any other place where decaying
matter is found
so spray the compost pile regularly
and the surrounding beams and timbers
here you may use dd and water suspension
as the visible residue will not be
objectionable
before spraying with ddt in water
remember to agitate the sprayer tank
to keep the ddt in suspension
in treating the staple you not only take
care of the common house fly
but other species as well that makes for
a better stable
the second rule of flight control is
treat the way stations at which flies
stop for food
garbage racks will draw flies for
hundreds of yards around
garbage should be removed at least once
daily either by the army
or by an approved contractor
the garbage must be properly disposed of
a sanitary fill is the preferred method
garbage can should be cleaned
immediately after disposal of the
contents
whether in a modern steam unit like this
one or in the old-fashioned way with the
bucket and water
don't expect ddt to substitute for
proper sanitation
a garbage rack can easily become a
breeding point and a waste station for
flies
keep it clean and spray it at regular
intervals
the garbage rack should be built with
drains to carry off wash water and
spilled garbage
not all garbage racks are constructed
with adequate drains
in this case the water runs off from the
rack
polluting the soil with organic matter
and forming a perfect medium for fly
breeding
so spray the general area around the
garbage depot
covering not only the ground but the
walls and the garbage cans themselves
now the third rule of fly control a very
simple one
keep them out
doors and windows must be thoroughly
screened
all screen doors should open outward to
make it more difficult for the flies to
enter
for treating screens several types of
screen applicators are available
a good application of ddt will make both
sides of the screen
sure death to flies
two men can treat all the screens of a
mess hall in about 20 minutes
the brush and roller type shown here
require approximately one quarter five
percent ddt
in kerosene to treat sixty to eighty
screens
one treatment of screens will continue
to kill flies for one or two months
the fourth and last rule of fly control
is
kill em when they do get in
in flight control it isn't necessary to
produce an all-over fog
or to contact the insects directly
just deposit a good residue on the
places where the flies tend to rest
their resting places are generally high
above waste level
on braces trusses uprights shelf edges
flies almost always a light on angles
and protruding edges where they can see
in both directions
look around for fly specs they'll help
you to identify their resting places
they very often rest on the pull cords
of lights and other dangling things
don't however spray electric wiring
light switches or lighted lamps
when you have finished your work look
around to make sure that every point has
been covered
an insect-free mess hall is essential to
the welfare and health of the camp as a
whole
a well-kept barracks and a well-kept
mess
are a check and a double check
for efficiency morale and health
you